Emma Watson and William McKnight have  officially called it quits after nearly  two years of dating each he has learned  the beauty and the beast' star Anitha  Lee split from her boyfriend  earlier this year news first broke of  the pair's relationship in early 2016  but Emma made a point to keep her  personal life out of the limelight this  passion with that the actress explained  why she remained notoriously private  about her romantic relationship  telling Vanity Fair in February quote  I've noticed in Hollywood who you're  dating gets tied up into your film  promotion and becomes part of the  performance and the circus she added I  would hate anyone that I were with to  feel like they were in any way part of a  show or an act I couldn't really pretend  that it wasn't gonna be a big deal  [Music]  you